okay uh from the standpoint of
jobs and unemployment things are
continuing to improve and i am
further reassured that what i uh told
you
yesterday would happen by september
october november is going to happen
all of these right wingers as i told you
yesterday are
very very worried about how it's more
profitable to be on unemployment
than to go back and work jobs at
restaurants
and retail stores and other places that
are now reopening as we exit the
pandemic
my position on this has been the
enhanced unemployment
has been one of the most effective
pieces
of coveted stimulus sure anecdotally
there are some people who are making
roughly the same or maybe even a little
bit more with that enhanced unemployment
and maybe they're choosing not to go
back to work for the time being
but that unemployment is going to end
and they're going to have no choice but
to go back to work
we're starting to see this increasingly
happen
and we now have a new report from yahoo
finance based on new department of labor
data
initial filings uh last week we just we
learned today on thursday we get the
numbers for the previous week
new jobless claims have dropped below
400 000 for the first time since march
of 2020 this is a fifth consecutive week
with a new low this is now a 14-month
low
fewer and fewer americans are becoming
newly unemployed
initial jobless claims came in at 385
000 just below the expected 387
thousand uh continuing claims
are at 3.77 million
slightly higher than the 3.6
million that were expected again this is
the first time
since the start of the pandemic where
new jobless claims have dropped below
400 000 and this is now starting to get
close to the pre-pandemic weekly rate
this is an important thing to understand
this is not a political statement this
is just what it is
in a good normal economy you still have
new unemployment claims every week
and you know we've talked before about
at what point
does the risk of going out in the world
get back to the baseline level because
it was never zero even before
kovid you could go out and catch the flu
you could catch a stomach bug
you could get run over by a bus etc so
it's about going back to the baseline
we were seeing even in the great economy
that i agree was was in place
uh during the trump administration
before the pandemic hit great in many
ways and yet we still had stagnant wages
and other issues
you still saw 200 something new uh 200
something thousand
new unemployment claims every week so
when you look at that number 385
it's almost back down to the pre
pandemic level
this is further evidence that as
people's unemployment benefits uh
continue
start to and continue to run out and as
more and more aspects of the economy are
reopened
as more and more people's kids go back
to school so that parents who don't have
child care can actually get back to work
we are going to see the issue that the
right
claims is a big issue of people just
hanging out at home
raking in the dough on unemployment it's
going to resolve itself the unemployment
is going to end the enhanced
unemployment ends in september
people state unemployment will
ultimately run out even with the various
extensions that different states provide
and people are going to have to go back
to work now there's going to be a real
question here
about whether we see stronger lobbying
efforts
uh for better wages and you know the the
economy is a complicated thing when we
say
what about a 15 minimum wage as i said
before there are parts of the country
where cost of living is so high that a
15
minimum wage is too low that's just the
reality there are other parts of the
country
where the cost of living is very very
low
and going to a 15 minimum wage
immediately
actually could be a significant shock to
the economy particularly states
that still have the federal minimum wage
as the prevailing minimum wage
and so these are really regionalized
issues much the same way
depending on which state you live in and
depending on what the cost of living is
and depending on what
the wages are that are being paid there
there are jobs that as a result of all
of this are probably going to have to
start paying people more in order to get
people to come back to work
part of that is going to be because of
some large businesses everything from
you know amazon bank of america has made
an announcement a
similar announcement have upped the
minimum wage that they are going to pay
this is going to lead to some businesses
having to pay more in order to attract
people
and that's okay now if you said they're
going to have to pay 100 bucks an hour
that's a straw man red herring that's
not an equilibrium minimum wage it's not
adjusted to cost of living it's not
adjusted to anything that makes sense
it's a straw man from the right
they love to say hey listen people
having more money is better
make the minimum wage 100 bucks an hour
make it a thousand bucks an hour
nobody's calling for that that's a
serious person because that's not an
equilibrium
wage tied to inflation productivity cost
of living or anything else
that being said remember that when
people
make more money that is a cost to the
employer
but then people in the community have
more money
to go and spend at that business imagine
a hardware store for example
this is often an example that's given
hardware store all of a sudden has a
higher wage they have to pay either
because of the minimum wage has gone up
or because
they need to raise wages to attract
workers they go from
eight bucks an hour to 12 bucks an hour
uh oh their payroll costs have just gone
up that's terrible right that'll kill
their business
well hold on a second if the entire
region now sees
a 12 minimum wage instead of eight you
now have
all sorts of people who because they are
earning more money
they're going to go to the hardware
store and say hey you know what i'm
going to get a new vacuum
or i'm going to get what i need to
refinish my floors or i'm going to
finish my basement or whatever the case
may be
and even though the hardware store now
has to pay more out in wages
they have all of these customers that
now have money to go and spend and do
projects so
revenue goes up as well this analysis
only works
within what we would consider an
equilibrium wage
it's really important to understand that
so
that's the latest in terms of
unemployment claims this is going to be
resolved
mostly on its own some businesses are
going to have to start paying more
there's no question about that because
they have been paying
sub market wages for a really long time
uh
and that is going to be a problem for
them for the most part this issue is
going to resolve itself i'm already
seeing it happen
in these numbers let me know your
thoughts you can find me on twitter at d
pacman we've got a really great show for
you today